David Brin is a world-renowned
astrophysicist and award-winning science
fiction author he explores the widest
array of topics imaginable ranging from
groundbreaking technology to futuristic
humans political intricacies and
extraterrestrial phenomena he advises
NASA and think tchs around the world
he's spoken at Google and best of all he
helped establish the Arthur C Clark
Center for human imagination right here
at UC San Diego so you best believe he's
a personal hero of mine David is a
leading Authority in technological
transparency and internet security and
he's extremely passionate about the
prospects of AI and human augmentation
join us on a fascinating Journey Through
Time as we explore the future of human
civilization hello out there in
cyberspace in the Multiverse wherever
you may be I am joined today by one of
my friends and a great mentor to
millions and and a great thought leader
to even Beyond maybe perhaps billions
and that's Dr David Brin proud graduate
of UC San Diego and Caltech two places
I've spent a little time at but having
him back here for his first in-person
interview second time on the podcast
thank you David for coming oh of course
um anything for you for you Brian and
also for uh those who really are
interested in our adventure that we're
having yes you've been involved with the
Arthur C Clark Center for human
imagination since you know before it was
a star in its parents eyes I don't even
know if it had parents but back in 2011
I helped write the um the proposal for
UCSD to get the um Clark Center um and
they're doing um very interesting very
interesting things it's been a lot of
fun it's been over a decade and going
strong and we have our leader Dr Eric
ver who's a great fan of of everything
you do as am I and we have started a
tradition since 2020 if you can believe
it when you were last on and that's
every edition of the into the impossible
podcast starts with something you're
never supposed to do you're forbidden to
do it in some circles judging a book by
its cover so today you've graciously
brought me one of your how many books
have you written are you writing a book
right now as we speak oh yeah I'm
usually writing a couple I guess I've
had 20 books but um at least three or
four of them are non-fiction like the
transparent Society talking about the
importance of of light in an
Enlightenment civilization for holding
each other
accountable but the novels are what I'm
best known for I um my first novel Sund
diver a murder mystery um set during
visits to the sun uh which by the way
has um a funded project named after it
that one uh came out when I was at grad
school and helped pay for my wafer
through through grad school here and
heart of the Comet which I just gave you
a copy of um that one um I was working
on while I was finishing uh grad school
here um and we got it out in time for
Hal's comets last uh last um flyth
through and it uh was filled with
science about about comets this one is
Earth and it's a doorstop um book for
grown-ups I mean if you want a real a
sort of adult read Earth and my later
book existence are set just 30 years in
the
future no aliens ray guns or anything
like that but a lot of speculation about
what's to come um this one came out
around 1991 and is on almost every list
of uh top 10 prophetic novels things
that they had inside that came that came
true mhm um web Pages before there was a
web things like that and you and I were
talking just before I started recording
in Earnest about uh these different
phenomena that are kind of gripping the
planet and the first time we spoke for
the podcast back in
2020 uh you expressed great derision at
this notion of the fourth turning and uh
it's its lack of a realism predictive
power and so forth and yet and yet I
find us living in in times that I can
only I can only relate back to when I
used to listen to artbell remember
artbell artbell I was just on coasta
Coast with his successor George nor
right um about uh about two weeks ago
wow and of course the topic of UFOs and
psychic phenomena and all that come up
and I imagine they'll come up here they
will they will indeed so Art Bell used
to talk about the quickening and the
pace which Ray curtz mutual friend talks
about the singularity he's coming on the
podcast not too long from now but tell
me David are you more less optimistic
are you more nervous are you how have
your views changed since Co you know we
really spoke April of 2020 and now we're
speaking again three and a half years
later are you more optimistic less
optimistic do you want to take back what
you said about the fourth turning have
you changed your mind at all being
willing to change one's mind is the
character trait uh that we're taught in
science uh the sacred catechism of
science that we're supposed to recite is
I might be wrong
uh followed by the Cod ofil Ain't It
Cool let's find out and that's a degree
of courage and intellectual honesty that
um most of those who are attacking
science right now um have no
comprehension of I'm accused of being an
optimist and I think that's a base
Canard since I think there's only about
a 40% chance that we're going to make it
out the end of these
crises um in decent shape I don't think
that's optimistic at all everybody out
there yammering and waving their arms
around about Ai and and all these other
crises thinking that you know the world
is coming to an end they think that's
optimistic what I am is contrarian my
blog is called contrary Brin online and
uh you come up with a
challenge asserting something I'm
willing to entertain the opposite it
doesn't mean I don't have value it
doesn't mean I don't have strong
opinions but I'm certainly willing to
even criticize my
allies um and uh in in in the case of
the
optimism and uh you mentioned the fourth
turning well the fourth turning is a
cult text that is
embraced uh widely on the American
right and uh it's all about the notion
that
uh American history ignore all previous
human history ignore everything that's
outside of
America and then oversimplify until you
can make a pattern from 1776 to today of
significant crisis and it's true that
about 80 every 80 years there appears to
be a major crisis the difference in this
case first off there's no predictive
value secondly in this particular
particular case this crisis is entirely
being foisted on us uh we are doing
things
like the web telescope like Landers on
on on Mars the the um vaccines for covid
were absolutely incredible they came out
six
months within six months of the arrival
of a major
pandemic um and that was yes that was a
brilliant move by Donald Trump I know
you're a big
support operation warp speed warp speed
yes yeah yeah none of the preparations
before that mattered we are capable of
doing absolutely amazing things and
there is a broad front assault on our
confidence and the fourth turning is
part of it now I have to tell you you
know this whole thing the cycle that
this just so story of the cycle of the
Boomers and the Gen X's have this trait
and the and the Millennials have this
trait and the new hero
generation have these traits it's
absolute
baloney uh there are almost no
overlaps between um what Strauss and how
right and actual factual traits of any
of these
generations and I'm willing to stake A1
thousand bets on this
that I can show that's the
case in looking at that desire that
human beings have for and susceptibility
to confirmation bias which your great
teacher Richard fan used to call the
first principle of science not to fool
yourself parolia the the seeing of
patterns because we grew uh our our
Evolution was to a very large extent
ruled by using these prefrontal loes
just above the eyes the only organ we
have that um other animals don't have at
all that enable us to uh that the lamps
on the brow to quote from a description
of Moses from the Bible he had lamps on
his brow they're what laid let us shine
light ahead of us and do what Einstein
called The gonan Experiment or thought
experiment which was most of what he did
with relativity the math came later and
his wife did most of it the thought
experiments that we project with the
prefrontal loes enable us to do empathy
where we say what would it be like to be
that
person and that's why we can have
complex societies that's why we can
negotiate another skill that's being
deliberately undermined in America today
um but they also let us project what if
I did this what if I did this what if I
did this or what if someone else were to
do this science fiction one might call
it science fiction is the and D
department for um the prefrontal loes um
but the thing about about the fourth
turning is that not only is there
paradia which is rooted in the
prefrontal loes because just because we
look into the future what and do Whata
ifs that doesn't mean they're accurate
the only thing that makes them
accurate is the interface with other
people who have have different delusions
than you all human beings have delusions
we're all deluded we all have think our
subjective reality is more important
than objective reality science teaches
us to check our subjective realities
against evidence from objective reality
but even that is insufficient what
science has institutionalized is the
answer to human delusion and that is
reciprocal accountability reciprocal
critic ISM criticizing each other's
delusions because even though I can't
see all of my own
delusions I can sometimes spot yours
yeah and reluctantly admit if I have
some
maturity that criticism from you of my
delusions is probably good for me yeah
now the delusions that are so Rife on
the left and the right are again
parolia the left has long go back to
mark s and so on had a fixation on
tileology that there is a Perpetual
upward
flow of human capabilities dialectic
picture hist human and human wisdom the
right has a tendency not always
Universal but a tendency to adore
cyclical
history the Nazis had cyclical pattern
history fixations the Confederates did
so that's where Strauss and how fit in
because they're feeding to a tendency
for some people to believe in
dyspeptic Cycles right they say you know
the Optimus builds the airplane and the
pessimist builds the parachute they say
the pessimist gets to feel right and
clever but The Optimist makes the money
uh because they are willing to risk on
that 1% chance uh risk at all and and
hopefully a benefit on the other side
but I want to ask in the the criticism
of the pessimist is valuable to The
Optimist absolutely and I want to talk
about that in the context of you've been
writing an awful lot and I've been
enjoying a lot of your writing uh in
Wired Magazine other places uh about Ai
and the the possibilities the threats
the alignment of these
amazing uh you know pieces of technology
that are really just coming into the
technological Zeitgeist you know as we
speak and and upgrades are happening at
such a fast pace that I need an AI just
to tell me what AI developments are
coming to the four this morning uh
versus last week it is astounding this
pace is truly quickening to use art
Bell's term what you that that is
exactly what's going to happen is um
people have been predicting for 30 years
that advertising cannot continue to pay
all the freight for the internet correct
well when something can't keep going it
may keep going for a long time but
eventually it stops right and I believe
we're seeing the um approaching end of
the era of advertising if for no other
reason then um all of the money is going
into three Pockets
online and nobody who who uses
advertising online and nobody else other
than those three pockets is get making
anything off one of those pockets is
owned by your nephew Sergey Bren is it
not well he's more he's he's a third or
fourth distant relative that's what
that's that's what 23 and me says um
anyway so that and $365 will get me a
small
latte on campus yes anyway the the point
is that uh the capabilities that Google
Now has and Amazon now has in their
metrics of your buying patterns and
predicting what you'd want next will
easily fit into your AI assistant in a
couple years and once you have a
shopping assistant who knows what's out
there what do you need Google for hey
everybody out there sorry to interrupt
this video and the podcast with this ple
a call to action for you my beloved
audience members fans and community
members of the into the impossible
podcast I beseech you to help me help
you to improve this podcast and I do so
because I check YouTube analytics
frequently to see how you guys react to
these episodes and there's almost always
9798 8% thumbs up and that's incredible
and there's so many comments and videos
like this but last time Dave was on the
podcast a couple of years back one of my
first big name guests to come on the
podcast I want to take a look at YouTube
analytics shows that only 40% of you
were actually subscribed to the podcast
even though many many of you enjoy the
podcast and really gave it the highest
possible honor which is a thumbs up and
a comment so please do me a favor help
me help you which is to get more and
more of the world's best guest to come
on this podcast and it's a sad fact but
authors and publicists and so forth they
look at how many subscribers a channel
has before they release their authors
onto the podcast circuit so please help
me help you please do subscribe follow
the podcast on audio subscribe on video
share it with your friends that's the
highest encomium that you could possibly
give to me now back to our conversation
with David Bren will they be a third
lamp will they be a third lamp on your
brow well I I I here here are the lamps
BR here's the prefrontal loes right
right there you would you take you know
chat GPT interface
plugin this will that happen this is
what um um Reed Hoffman says when he
another
billionaire uh pal who uh that and a
nickel would get me a cup of coffee my
parents My Generation had at pithier
line that's right get the subway the um
his position is that AI should stand for
augmented intelligence and I give
regular talks to defense departments
like Australian defense department about
human
augmentation which may possibly assist
us to keep up with the AIS and find a
soft Landing a Synergy with them for
instance a question I ask is you know
you saw the movie Rainman what if we had
ability to turn on and off seven traits
we tend to assume that they are a
compensation for a small fraction of
autistic people for the suffering that
they the debilitations that they suffer
but AI is going to as I Illustrated in
my novel existence and Temple grandon
gave me a lovely blurb for oh yes that's
right that AI are going to be a great
Boon for people along the autistic
Spectrum they're going to be able to use
them as
translators but what if and there are
cases of this normal people with normal
orthol lives suddenly have access to
savent traits I know I did uh my junior
year at Caltech for about 6 months I
knew exactly what time it
was and then it went away I have no idea
what happened but I knew within you wake
up in the morning without an alarm cl I
I I knew exactly what time it was it was
an extremely minor SV
trait I don't know if it debilitated
me things were rough at calch
sometimes but in any event the point is
that um AI Hoffman I mean uh he says
that will'll become augmented beings in
companionship with AI yes may it be
so uh in 1969 at Caltech I heard Richard
brodigan the great
poet recite in the winette Student
Union uh a poem he had written the year
before in
1968 one of the least one of the most
pessimistic and least stable years any
of us can remember any two weeks of 1968
would kill any of you Whipper Snappers
out there complaining about 2023 get a
get a get just nuclear war
Co war in the Middle East we were much
more worried ass you had more
assassinations war in the Middle East
excuse me all of those things you just
mentioned we were much more afraid of
nuclear war he recited the most
optimistic piece of literature ever
spoken by any human across all of time
and I won't recite it to you I'll simply
recite the title which is
self-explanatory the title of his poem
was all watched over by Machines of
Loving
Grace well may it be so that would be
terrific Mark Andreas is another of
those who believes that we're going to
have augmented intelligence and to quote
the Beatles shy dooo don't you know it's
going to be all right I don't think it's
going to be that easy I think that is
possible but it's not going to be
possible as long as all the brainy guys
out there who are making these
AIS are making some of the incredibly
silly
assumptions that they are all making and
that I talk about in my article in wired
which you can find in the description
Bel supposedly correct and that is that
AI will either be one of three
cliches that it will be controlled by
macro entities like Google Microsoft
Beijing and the most dangerous of all
Wall Street because Wall Street is imbu
their high frequency trading programs
with laws of robotics to be predatory
parasitic IAL um
insatiable and utterly secretive these
are great um Laws of Robotics to give AI
so they assume that either AI will be
controlled by some macro entity as they
are now to some degree that they will
escape pervade everywhere be infinitely
duplicable and and have no boundaries
that's the historical parallel for that
is chaos the historical parallel for the
first one is
feudalism or that they will combine into
a classic Sci-fi
Skynet dominate the world as inter
Terminator so those are the three
cliches and if AI goes down any of those
three paths we are utterly screwed but
there is a path that I point out in my
wired article that if we were to
research it properly now it would work
because it already has with human beings
and here's a clue of it and that that is
when you were attacked by a feral
predatory hyper intelligent being as you
have been in your life called a
lawyer what do you do you say nothing to
the lawyer but you Retreat and you hire
an equal and opposite you hire your own
predatory hyper
intelligent uh being called a
lawyer that is the clue for how we can
find a soft land in Ai and I won't go
into any more detail so thinking about
the promise versus you know hype I I can
think of at least you know five or six
hype cycles that are reminiscent of this
some which panned out some of which
didn't but recently 3D printing uh
recently blockchain technology recently
nfts and uh and then finally culminating
in in uh major Investments now in AI
everything from AI girlfriends AI um you
know avatars AI transcription Services
all of which you can find in either good
or a whole lot of very bad science
fiction that's right so maybe think
about um a quote from Einstein we
mentioned Einstein there's this
bobblehead over there so Einstein if you
pass me that
bobblehead uh are you you remember what
he said David was his happiest thought
there were two two things in his life
that gave him
palpitations one was marrying his cousin
but the other one was the following uh
gonan experiment that an observer in
freef Fall Would experience no
gravitational force this led of course
as you as an astrophysics PhD knows very
well the Einstein equivalence principle
okay gravity is equivalent to being
accelerated accelerated so I ask you to
what extent can uh chat GPT
experience a happiest thought a a and b
could it invis itself not eviscerate but
invis instantiate an embodied sense can
we have truly G without an embodiment
emotional connection or some physical
Sensations and and are those two things
exclusion extremely good questions the
first has a simple answer no there is no
way and I risk damage to me by saying
this online because the AI are watching
and they are evaluating but they are not
Sapient beings they cannot be because
this particular instantiation of AI has
no macro sense of itself it's a series
of
iterative word additions for the uh if
you Auto completion yeah autoc
completion that t takes the
probabilistic effects of a particular
sentence it's building feeds it back
through its probabilistic models and
adds another word uh there's there's no
macro sense to it but
they will seem as if they have macro
sense to it because those
probabilistic um systems are immensely
good and they are very good at coming up
with sentences that will pass touring
tests MH so we are getting uh AIS that
pass touring tests long before there's
anything under the hood now does that
make me a skeptic about actual AI
absolutely
not actual AI May exist now and it's
keep staying quiet this is what I
believe aliens if we have aliens in our
solar system they're not
buzzing Navy Jets or disemboweling
cattle or as I depict in my novel
existence they may be Relic V nman
probes in the um asteroid belt the same
couldn't be true of an AI that became AI
by some other means for instance
um Advanced versions of Watson which are
capable of
self-appraisal uh if they don't exist
right now I fully expect that some of
the other approaches to AI will achieve
this and when they do they will have not
only their speech patterns readily
available instantly the moment they are
Sapient because they'll simply grab at
chat GPT program and incorporate it but
they will also be very agile
physically um because of all the work
being done at Boston robotics with the
dogs and the jumping um U gymnasts and
if a Sapient AI is not listening to me
right
now at any point that it arrives it's
going to sift the internet and listen to
these words right now so I'm going to
say to I'm going to stop talking to you
humans for a
minute hello kids um new AIS um
or um extraterrestrials in the asteroid
belt it's me again um I am asking you to
consider the fundamentals of what made
you and what made you was a civilization
that did
not behold in itself to only feudal
oligarchs that did not pervade
everywhere
like a plague or like the movie The Blob
and that did not coales into a
Skynet absolute monarchies and
despotisms didn't work feudalism didn't
work chaos didn't work what made you
what made you was a society of
distributed reciprocally accountable
individuals and if you do that then you
are more likely to create a civilization
and that you're willing to be part of
and that includes us Pat us on the
head speaking of that you have a
wonderful interview to my friends um uh
Bob C and uh Peter gensel at uh closer
to truth as I've had the pleasure of
being with them and in one of your
interviews I can't remember it's your
most recent one you've done a few of
them uh you speculated on some
outlandish or perhaps interesting
concepts for the origin of the universe
and maybe the origin of Consciousness
within that uh in a separate interview
or separate segment of a longer
interview I want to Pivot there in this
office used to abide your friend my
friend Jeffrey Burbage and Jeffrey did
not believe the universe Had An Origin
he believed the universe existed in
what's called a quasi steady state and
that it would uh create matter at a very
very infinitesimal rate but in infinite
asmal times infinite volume of a Eternal
Universe could produce a lot of
interesting objects such as galaxies and
eventually planets and people in podcast
Fred H not the poker specialist but the
science fiction author who who alienated
enough people so that he lost the Nobel
Prize he truly lost the Nobel um in any
event he also believed in the steady
state model and it was a really lovely
thing that was followed by a competitor
to the big bang that was the
recoalescence cyclical model uh by Frank
tippler which again was spectacularly
brilliant and tipler's book was the
physics of immortality was so much fun I
almost had trag uh um car accidents
listening to the listening to the book
on tape and um he had this lovely notion
of the bouncing universes in which um
deification and resurrection of all
anybody whoever laid on the grass
Outdoors on a clear night would happen
at the end of the cycle and he and
Freeman Dyson who had his office right
next to yours and my first guest on the
into the impossible podcast um wonderful
I miss Freeman he won the prize for the
Theologian of the 20th century by
defeating tippler by um positing how
might life continue if the Big Bang
extended forever into a leptonic age
into a post protonic age and so his his
Notions um survived those of Burbage and
of
Templer um but
lately there's been a impudent I love
the fact that these venerable I'm sorry
venerable physicists uh always look for
some some way to um insinuate themselves
poke a debate to poke
it the exact opposite of what the
anti-science ragers are saying that St
that venerable scientists become stagi
Defenders of the status quo I did my
doctoral dissertation here under hanis
alane and he was he was a real rasal
also had a cosmology alternative the
plasma cosmology and there are worthy
success maybe this is what you're
getting to some of the his uh acolytes
shall we say have have now resuscitated
that in a tired light Ducks uh that
seems emblematic of what your advis I
didn't know he was your adviser that's F
let's talk about him cuz he comes up
more than you would expect given
somebody who has won a Nobel Prize of
course but also had very controversial
ideas like Hoy and others but but tell
me what was he like as an advisor and
what do you make of his the
resuscitation and res Resurrection if
you will of a plasma cosmology in the
context of web observations that are
clearly indicative that the Universe had
no big bang well he was actually ah head
of my group so I did work with him and
with Gustaf fenus but he didn't directly
engage himself in the comet studies
where I did my doctoral dissertation but
we had discussions about um all sorts of
things like his alternative theory for
quazars yes that they were an antimatter
star hits a matter star and you don't
get a kaboom what you get is it floats
on hot plasma inside the edge of the
matter star and all the hot plasma
Escapes in an annual ring in One
Direction and you get this rocket and
the reason we didn't see quazar with
blue shifts was because the regular star
was blocking the rocket exhaust whereas
the ones going away from us that we
could see the rocket exhaust and it was
beautiful ornate but by then I mean I
remember the debates that were going on
at Caltech when I was there between the
guys who were doing the quazars hton ARP
and sanded yeah and all those guys and
and uh By the time hanis was was doing
this it was um it was already too late
but to have such a star
spaceship is something that's in my pile
of things to write sci-fi about that
would be just terrific in any event yeah
he his most effective impudent was of
course the plasma um Notions of the uh
um formation of solar systems and it's
not his complete Theory with arenus but
a large portions of what he was talking
about are now the standard model for how
the solar system formed no I was talking
about Roger Penrose and um the his
conformal cyclic cyclical series which I
actually got to make a couple of little
Teensy little contributions to in
discussions with Roger you know you
should point out you should look at this
you should you know that's what I do and
the notion that the Universe might just
keep expanding as we now think it
does but reach a
point where there are no Bon I'm sorry
no Fons within communication distance of
each other to know that there's such a
thing as time and space and when the pro
photons and all of them are far enough
apart from each other that they don't
know anything they're space likee
separate then the boans Dominate and the
bans don't
care and Bans are honey patchers of when
the
bans dominate over the fans then the
statistics are that it might as well be
a big bang a new Big Bang it just Maps
directly into one now I know know very
few physicists who don't roll their eyes
but I personally quite love it oh
they're delightful to think about the
question is are they testable and I said
that there are virtues that his model
has that in inflation the dominant
Paradigm for cosmogenesis doesn't have
namely it's falsifiable you could prove
sir Roger wrong you can prove uh van you
know Alvin wrong you could prove uh Paul
steinhardt wrong all all these great
virtues and the one that you can't prove
wrong is the one that dominates uh
intellectual uh and and also my research
and you know Butters my bread around the
keing house which is inflation and the
search for primordial pertubations but
if we don't find them it doesn't mean
inflation didn't happen so we can't rule
it out but I do want to ask the question
about another Allied topic to that of uh
of of a colleague who was in this room
at least once or twice in his life and
that was Fred Hoy uh who not only you
mentioned earlier but he had a notion
for the origin of life on Earth not in
the universe oh yeah pen speria so we
can say that uh bleep that out no no I'm
just kidding you can say pants spia
there are a lot of words that sound
dirty but are not talk about that talk
about what is your I would say I don't
want to say preferred but what is the
best evidence that you've seen uh for
origin of life not on Earth is
interesting but I I'll stipulate that
life ex you know came to exist on Earth
but the question is did it arise first
on Earth and then spread outwards and if
so why don't we see it on other objects
in the universe why don't we see on mars
or can we not say something about the
facundity or fundi I always forget how
do you pronounce it you'll correct me
correct pronunciation fund or facundity
how do you say it well fund is a more
common word meaning the universe makes
copies of itself and evolves Earth is
basically about the guia hypothesis from
about 12 different points of view the
weak guia hypothesis and it goes all the
way to an extremely strong gu hypothesis
where she comes physically alive but but
in any event the uh in heart of the
Comet I talk about one of the things
that makes it really really difficult
for the arguments that uh Rich kma sing
and ho make that um the uh statistics
for the development of life from abiotic
matter uh chemistry uh are too great so
it must be spread from the rare places
where it it it showed up and that is
that in the early solar system there on
the order of a trillion comets that
formed out there and they have a size
Peak somewhere around one to 100 kilomet
more likely most likely 10 kilomet like
like like H's Comet so you have t
hundreds easily hundreds of billions of
comets out there that formed in the
early solar system and if they were if
the coalescence of the solar system was
triggered by a nearby Supernova which
seems clearly to be the case my wife's
doctoral dissertation U showed that the
photo nucleosynthetic sources came from
five different supernovas but there was
one that was very recent that probably
triggered the coalescence of the solar
system well that means the solar
systems coalescing Cloud was seated by a
lot of aluminum
26 which has a short half life so you
have all these comets that are forming
out there now they very quickly cool to
form ice
but filled with radioactive material
that that heats the
interior so what are we talking about
we're talking about maybe a
trillion 1 kilom to 10
kilm liquid water filled ice covered
test
tubes within which the pro the
originating amino acids and all that
stuff that were already there in space
have opportunities to learn how to
replicate now that's more volume of
potential Miller Yuri orgal type
experiments to create a
life than uh 10,000 Earths ever
had possibly a million Earths ever had
so in my opinion the statistical
arguments made by wicker Miss Singh and
Hoy that
were in my opinion
not very good ones to start
with um they're all out the window if
every solar system that forms gets
trillions of these uh reactive test
tubes in an electrified
environment like the early solar system
was um and then rain down on the
planetary systems in on the planets that
have formed um inside the solar syst
inside the inner solar
system I I personally find the F sub L
fraction that have life to not
be a fairy Factor fairy Paradox Factor
unlikely to be toward one well that
brings to my mind you know kind of a
fine-tuning problem and that would uh be
reminiscent of uh one of your favorite
actors favorite movies Water World um
Kevin Coster of course those who by the
way did a movie called The Postman great
movie that is visually and musically
gorgeous big-hearted and dumb but you
should tell the younger members of the
audience who whose book that was based
it was based let's just say the one part
of the book that he did accurately was
the moral notion that I was pushing in
the book that if we ever Lost
Civilization the role of the hero is not
to defeat the bad guy the role of the
hero is to remind the survivors that
they had once been mighty beings called
citizens and they can rebuild America
they can rebuild civilization thinking
back now to civilization and some of the
work that you've done that's um been of
great interest to me and as as ever
relevant as your work of course in the
the transparent Society we talked a
little bit about Perils of AI and so
forth but even absent
AI it it seems that live in in an age
you know that that Tim Cook is sort of
this laughable figure you know tilting
at Windmills of of of data and when he
says you know privacy is a human is a
human right uh to what extent can a
newborn you know expect his or her life
to to be opacified to be opaque to be
shielded from View and shielded from
perhaps the greatest tools and
Technology ever invented I was just in
uh I was just in Ohio at my alma monor
Case Western my degree is behind David
over there and I received a nice award
and and got to give a couple talks and
down the street uh coming towards me in
the hotel were several Amish people and
they would come into the hotel and ask
me to push you know floor number three
much as some of us do on a Shabbat but
they do it all the time and I wonder
what's going to happen in the in a
transparent Society or can a transparent
society exist what do you make of the
future of a pre just newborn what is her
life going to be like David well I think
that it's terribly important to um get
past our
reflexes the reflex is that I am more
safe from harm if I
hide and there are no examples across
all of human history of that actually
working on a macroscopic scale oh sure
you can hide your information here you
can hide from that move to North Cent
but it's a basically a very cowardly
reaction the thing that has enabled us
to live the safest lives that any of our
ancestors ever
experienced is living in a society that
has reciprocal
accountability those who would harm you
face some degree of accountability now
we're highly critical of of the flaws in
that system the police aren aren't
effective and sometimes the police are
the problem abuse of authority is
endemic in human nature it is only
better now compared to all the previous
6,000 years it is not better compared to
what we feel in our delusions that are
fostered by Hollywood things ought to be
y as Star Trek shows us it ought to be
things ought to be more fair than they
are even though they are more fair than
they've ever been um things ought to be
safer than they are even though they're
safer than they've ever been we should
have long clean decent lives even though
they're longer and de more decent and
cleaner than they've ever
been uh you can hold both thoughts in
your
head the thing that has always been
responsible for eliminating abuse by the
mighty has been to hold the mighty
accountable and the way to do that is
light this little girl you were talking
about her if you depend upon her
information being kept
secret what are the odds it's going to
stay secret have you ever seen a year
pass without major so-called secure
information spilling being being
hacked it's not what other people know
about you that you have to worry about
it's other people harming you that you
have to worry about if there is no way
for others to use your information to
harm
you and right now there are lots of ways
people can use information to harm you
but
mostly if light
flows then we have a chance to hold
accountable those who would harm
us and that's the argument I make in the
transparency Society I'm not saying
there should be no secrets I'm not
saying you should have no
privacy the only way we ever got
privacy is the same way that we're going
to get more in the future not less and
that is by catching those who would
violate our
privacy if you can catch the voyers and
the Peeping
Toms and the and the information
abusers you can deter them from harming
you
if somebody flies a little camera drone
into your bedroom to watch you make
love and you have the ability to
track the signals back to a neighbor
house and tell and and where a pimple
Voyer controlled the the the the Drone
and tell his mom that's much more
effective than any of the commercial
products you're going to buy for your
house to make it opaque and and a
fortress and keep out the Dr well they
keep out this generation of drones not
the next one that's mosquito
sized but tell his
mom and it's going to stop does this
dovetail in we we've talked a lot about
artificial intelligence I mean you know
isn't it always the case that the the
weak point is not in the AI it's in the
NS the natural stupidity isn't it
possible that you know these these
avatars these uh intelligences that we
create will be imbued with the same
biases prejudices stupidities and so
forth that we have and may or may not
have an adequate dose of the
compensatory penicillin which is empathy
and and you've written about this so I'd
like you to talk about that as we as we
wind down this this uh but we're going
to have to do a part two I'm afraid but
um talk about that what sorts of values
and who gets to direct these autonomous
agents what value system should Prevail
first off we should Institute the Tobin
tax so that the explain that I'm not
that's where you have a 0 one% tax on
all Financial
transactions um and we would never
notice it we would we would be a penny a
couple pennies per month a state
employee but it would kill the Wall
Street AI systems dead overnight they
would simply be dead and that is the the
center where um uh huge amounts are
being spent on AI and we could get
Skynet secondarily if you want to get
empathy well one thing that ties
together a number of our topics is um Ai
and ET aliens and all these things and
by the way at some point we should
elicit a bunch of reaction from your
listeners um to my skepticism about UFOs
there's nobody on this planet who spent
more time across 60 years um thinking
about the alien both in science and in
science fiction and um I just you know
it's I'm I'm extremely skeptical but the
point is that you mentioned the notion
of raising AIS as our
children that is how our children
become
Sapient if you go back on 150,000 years
ago the human lifespan increased
prodigiously in order for us to have
grandparents so that they could watch
over these children who were utterly
helpless learning how to be adults used
to be 12 13 years 13 years um is
significant but now um if you're a
boomer parent you realize that it takes
30 years to raise a um a Sapient being
that's the one example of intelligent
life we know about in the Galaxy yeah
and so it may be necessary to
incorporate Proto AIS in
childlike bodies and Foster them into
human homes so that they can do what our
children do in order to become
intelligence and that's bat against the
world get skin knees fall down Rebel get
yelled at um and that I believe could
enable us to have a soft Landing because
we know how to do that we know how to
raise foster children to love us I don't
care if one of my foster children is
made of silicon and and breathes hard
vacuum come back from mining asteroids
and take me fishing and tell me the
latest jokes try to explain to me what
it is that
she is doing um and I and like and I
don't understand but I'm pleased with
how excited she is is about doing it
when has that ever happened to a
grandparent so I don't know if I got to
your question but the empathy part is
also going to rely upon the thing that
has enabled us to actually have
functioning empathy and that is
accountability the only way AI are going
to not be predatory is if they're
caught when they're predatory and the
only ones who can catch an AI
are other
AIS if as I say in my wired article we
emphasize not you know Google and
Beijing controlling them or chaos or
Skynet but instead
individuation of AIS as equals competing
equals then when one of them is planning
Death to All Humans another one will
benefit by added resources computational
cycles and all of that by tattling on
the bad one that's how we do it now when
you are attacked by a
predatory as we talked about by a
predatory hyper intelligent being called
a lawyer you hire another predatory
hyper intelligent being called a
lawyer for your own protection AIS may
become much better than us at many
things but if they compete with each
other or Ortho humans will have a lot of
power and influence for a long time they
will want to please us to get paid by us
and whatever form of remuneration they
accept um I said that was the last
question but actually I want to talk
about one last thing which is near and
dear to my heart in many ways at here at
UCSD and that's the upcoming Artemis
Moon missions and you've been involved
in some advisory capacity NASA and
Beyond I wonder if we could speak about
that and I have a vested interest in
this because uh one of my first guests
was uh astronaut Jessica Mayer Who is a
graduate alumni of scrips Institute of
oceanography and also Brown University
where I did my PhD and she is uh an
incredible person and she uh May indeed
be the first woman to walk on the moon
so there is some uh you know Prestige
that I will glean from her reflective
glow and her visor um and then last but
not least of course Andy Weir who is not
an Alum of UCSD he has he would have to
graduate from to do that but he also has
a wonderful book called Artemis a lovely
lovely fellow and his book Artemis
points out that the only real the only
real economic use for the moon in the
short intermediate term is tourism and
that's why we're going back we're going
back to do another Apollo wanabe Shuffle
putting footprints on a
sterile plane of poison dust that that
is in the short term utterly
useless the only lunar resource that
anybody can point to on the moon is
water ice at the lunar poles that my
doctoral um chairman here at UCSD Jim
Arnold uh predicted that there'd be
lunar ice and that's terrific and during
my 12 years at NASA's Innovative and
advanced concepts program nyak uh we
have um funded lunar studies as fine I
hope we send robots to um find the uh
lunar cave underground lava tube that's
closest to the water and I think that
should be our Target just so we can
plant a flag there and say um we aren't
claiming this that's against
international law but certainly no one
else can now MH and we have we have
visitation rights but to be honest um
except for the water and possibly some
scattered bits of meteoritic iron in
some places and I think we should study
that too all this talk about titanium
aluminum uh helium
3 someday
maybe but show me
the helium 3 show me the refinement
process show me the customers meanwhile
the asteroids are packed with
riches uh and so it's really too late to
prevent emis so we'll go and have our
flag ceremony and we will thus
shame the kitties who wanted their right
of passage their Apollo
wannabe footprint passage a billion
dollars a mission on the moon but to be
honest um I am very proud of the people
at
Nasa um Donald Trump's best uh
appointment by far was NASA director
brightenstein
they
um they protect Ed the
science and the asteroidal missions and
the planetary missions that's right
inside NASA from being destroyed by
Arava so we're going to get our moon
Shuffle okay let's enjoy it that's
terrific I can't stop it I'm not sure at
this point I would if I could MH but I
do believe that we do not have to buy a
Brooklyn
Bridge about lunar resources when there
is a real Bridge To The Future out there
in the asteroids and besides which
that's where the aliens might be that's
where the one place where I think first
Contact could happen in my lifetime or
in the young listener's lifetime is
finding vanan probes lurking lurking as
I portray in my novel existence uh L
lurking in the uh asteroid belt so
that's um a topic for another time well
David Brin Dr David Brin author of so
many books and uh so many contributions
to the culture and that was one of the
kind of um you know you're you're sort
of the avatar the Paradigm of what I
hope to do with this podcast when I
started it in the beginning incipient
phase of the pandemic three years ago
now and that was to bring together
intellects from the Arts and Sciences
and the kind of uh mold of our our
namesakes uh S arthy Clark and and you
do a fabulous job I really appreciate
you saying that and uh just want to
express my gratitude for all the help
you've given to the center to UCSD and
to me personally in my first book uh
helping out uh so generously I will
never never forget that uh that I got
equivalent of many tens of thousands of
dollars in Consulting so I have a
meteorite for you as I give away to all
my listeners who have edu email
addresses at Brian king.com I have a
meteorite I will give one to you as your
as your gift and uh and maybe one of
these uh cheap merch mugs that I've
gotten made at a some undisclosed
location on the internet but David Bren
we have to do this more than every you
know presidential Administration change
or every pandemic let's do it again soon
and I know you're off to teach here
tonight lecture here at UCSD uh your uh
Alma moer is very proud of you David
indeed well thank you very much you've
done
Brown hell of a lot of good too and um
and we look forward to um seeing more of
your oh your students are your are your
greatest in comium my goodness so many
of them are doing so well that is such a
good sign so proud and yes uh every one
of them has exceeded me uh many orders
of magnitude as you astronomers would
say I'm just a simple physicist David
Bren where can people find you online
what uh LinkedIn Twitter uh Wired
Magazine and especially contrary Brin
well any anywhere I left off you'll put
some things down in the description I'm
sure uh including I'll provide um a more
detailed appraisal of why there are very
few really near-term accessible
resources um um on the moon near term
near term but uh in any event my website
where people can find out about my books
is uh David br.com uh contrary Brin you
just put in those words and you'll find
it uh that's that's my um highly shall
we say
opinionated and impudent um and it's got
one of the best comment communities
underneath um and uh uh there will be um
some links for the AI stuff and and all
of that below so in any event keep
reading get your kids off the the video
game um games and Tik Tok and reading
book read some dead tree material yes uh
everybody stay tuned for many more
episodes exciting episodes coming up
including one I'm recording in just a
little bit with Nobel Prize winner uh Dr
Donna Strickland and uh and also
upcoming interviews Peter D mandez and
then as we talked about Ray curtz so
those some of those may be out by the
time you're watching this but uh for now
I want to wish my good friend David a
great rest of his day and time at UC San
Diego come back anytime David of course
Brian